[Music]
thank you very much for choosing this
talk over the the sunny weather outside
so today I'll be introducing you how to
deploy your own data science environment
in the cloud using open source projects
such as Jupiter and kubernetes so yeah
I'm the software engineer and the data
engineer and I've mostly worked with
Python Java and go and in data heavy
industry such as finance and machine
learning so I run a platform called
spine labs which helps people deploy
manage Jupiter hub solutions in the
cloud and I love talking about Python or
coffee and cats so if any of those are
interesting come find me after the talk
right so by a show of hands who in this
room already uses Jupiter notebooks for
for something ok almost everyone so
you'll be very familiar with this user
interface this is a demo that I've set
up at PI data demo dot spine labs that
IO you can log in with github and have a
play around if you so wish let's hope it
doesn't crash but basically yeah
Jupiter notebook is an interactive
computing environment that allows you to
run code produce graphics upload files
and things like that so it's very useful
if you're running a big team or teaching
a data science class or have a research
group where people need to be able to
run code in various kinds of languages
so the Jupiter project began its life as
an interactive Python computing
environment called ipython it was first
developed by Fernando Paris a PhD
students at UC Berkeley I believe and
those of us who've been around in the
Python community for a while remember
this as the better version of the Python
shell so since that point the ipython
project which is now known as the
Jupiter project has grown to support a
large ecosystem of programming languages
so these days it's not just for Python
programmers and data scientists but also
our friends in the our community and the
Julia community among I think a hundred
of
programming languages can take advantage
of this computing environment in
addition to supporting lots of different
programming languages there are also
many auxiliary sub projects such as
Jupiter hub which helps you manage a
large-scale deployment of Jupiter and
also Jupiter lab which is the next
generation user interface for
interactive computing so in addition to
this there is a very active open-source
community around this project there is a
conference that takes place every year
in New York about Jupiter and in
addition to that it's been adopted
across a wide variety of scientific
disciplines and industries and very
recently because of the improvements in
the user interface and the large
ecosystem of data science packages that
it supports it's been seen as a serious
contender for proprietary solutions such
as Mathematica and if you're interested
in things such as reproducible research
and things being able to share your code
you should read Paul roamers article
where he compares the Jupiter project to
Mathematica and he explains why it's
been better for reproducible science
that people are moving away from closed
source proprietary solutions so in
addition to Jupiter hub which I'll be
talking about today I wanted to bring to
your attention to new projects that are
gaining some ground in the Jupiter
ecosystem so the first one is Jupiter
lab it was released a few months ago and
it's the next-generation user interface
so as you can see from the screenshot
it's a bit more advanced in the sense
that it allows you to do more than the
classic Jupiter notebook user interface
that I demoed a while ago and the second
really cool project that's been recently
deployed is binder hub and this allows
you to create custom computing
environments from a github repository so
if you're interested interested at my
binder org you can put in the URL of
your github repository and it will spin
up a Jupiter notebook with those
dependencies installed so it's actually
really cool if you want to share your
work with someone else you can simply
point them to this URL alright so back
to Jupiter hub so most of you in this
room are probably more than capable of
installing your own Jupiter notebook
server on your own machine but this
quickly starts to break down if you run
a large class for people who don't come
from computer science backgrounds or if
you're in an enterprise situation and
you've perhaps have some people who are
not familiar with the Python package
management ecosystem so you very quickly
run into a massive headache
you have compilation errors installation
errors people start having what's known
as an installation drift so someone has
version X of some kind of Python package
and another person has version block Y
so you get it works on my machine
situation but not on everyone else's
machine in addition in classes for
example if you're teaching a Python
class you might have people who have
Windows machines that don't have
administrator privileges for example and
this can be a problem for some packages
so a solution to this is to deploy a
unified environment in the cloud using
jupiter hub so to take a bit of a look
at jupiter help internals and what's
happening so we have two familiar
components here we have the user's
browser which is what all of you used to
interact with your single user server
and then we have the jupiter notebook
which is the component that actually
listens to your command talk to the
python kernel behind the scenes to
execute your code and then sends the
results back to your browser to display
to you jupiter hub sits in between these
two components and it has three main
tasks so first authentication this is
super important we're going to be
letting people execute code on our
server so we have to make sure that we
only allowed for people who are
authorized to do this second check if a
user is new if they don't have a
previous jupiter notebook server running
then we have to spin up a new server for
them and redirect all of their browser
requests to the server if we already
know this user then we simply have to
redirect so it actually happens behind
the scenes when you deploy jupiter hub
is you get two components you have the
actual hub which is a Python process
that leverages tornado it does all of
the main logic behind jupiter hub so it
authenticates users and then it spawns
the single user jupiter notebook servers
on a machine of your choice now there is
a second component here that's probably
not as well known and that's the proxy
this is the public facing component of
jupiter hub and it's
the first component that receives a
users request when you try to interact
with Jupiter through the browser so the
proxy actually has several jobs first it
checks if it already has an an entry for
the user in its dynamic routing table if
it does that means we are already seeing
this user and we've authenticated them
and that means we can simply redirect
the requests to their server if not then
the proxy redirects the users requests
to the hub which then sets up the server
for the user and adds a new entry in the
proxies table so that the next time the
user talks to the proxy they can
immediately be routed to their single
user network so there is a there's a
live system running there so if you
logged in - if you saw the URL where I
was doing a demo behind the scenes this
is what's happening this is a kubernetes
cluster I'll talk about kubernetes a bit
later in the presentation but this is
running on Google Cloud and as you can
see there are several pods which is just
an abstraction over a process and you
can see there is a hub which does the
authentication and spawning and there is
also a proxy which is the public facing
component and then there by the looks of
it there is one notebook which is the
one that I started so if you run this
again okay
someone else is on the system that's
great so if we take a look at the proxy
logs we can quickly see that this new
user whoever you are thank you for
trying it out they've logged in and the
proxy has has talked to the hub
authenticated the user and then it's
basically added a new entry into the
table so the next time the user uses
this system they'll be automatically
routed to their single user notebook
okay
mm-hmm yeah I'm sorry about that
you can upload your own I think but okay
let's keep let's keep moving so let's
talk a bit about what happens if you
want to deploy Jupiter hub in production
so what are some of the challenges that
you may face so first of all you have
lots of users on your clusters so you
need to manage CPU and memory resources
responsibly whether a user is malicious
or not they might accidentally start up
some kind of thing that takes up all of
the available CPU capacity and memory
resources and cause everyone else's
performance to suffer a lot so that's
probably number one of your concerns you
have to manage cleaning up resources if
you're running a large class of let's
say a thousand users you won't be able
to do all of this manually you have to
be able to scale your computer resources
up and down depending on the load so if
you're running a data science class for
example and everyone logs in at 8 a.m.
and you have a thousand users you have
to be able to handle that without manual
intervention and then last but
definitely not least you have to worry
about security especially if you're in
an enterprise environment and you're
handling some kind of sensitive data you
have to be able to secure the connection
between the browser client the Jupiter
server and also whatever the Jupiter
server talks to in order to get the data
so let's step aside from the data
science aspect of this for a moment and
let's talk about some of the recent
developments in the infrastructure
software engineering space and see how
those can help us address these
challenges so first of all something
that you've all probably heard about is
containers so a container is a logical
concept that uses a collection of
features introduced into the Linux
kernel to isolate processes from one
another and to make sure that they don't
use more CPU or memory than is allocated
to them so basically it's like
lightweight virtualization that uses the
host machines operating system although
it's been very popular in the past 10
years container technologies actually by
no means new it's been around since the
1980s in its earliest versions but it
didn't really take off until
2006 when Google contributed a Linux
kernel patch that introduced control
groups which are one of the key features
that enable modern container technology
containers didn't get particularly
popular until a company called docker
made it very easy for people to create
container images that could be shared
through repositories to to store them
and to run them remotely and yes you can
probably tell the container space has
certainly exploded since then so
containers solved the first challenge
that we have they isolate the process
and they also make it very easy to
deploy applications that have
dependencies such as Python data science
applications you might have dependency
on numpy scifi lots of other different
things so containers solve those two
things for us so for Jupiter hub
installation we would need a container
to run a jupiter notebook server for
each user depending on the number of
users on your platform this could be in
the thousands we also need something to
run the hub and the proxy and to make
sure that those are running through the
whole duration when our system should be
up so for a small deployment of five or
six people you might be able to do this
manually packaging them up in containers
then logging in to whatever server is
going to be serving this and and running
the necessary commands there but for
larger scale deployments you need to
think about what if your machine fails
whether it's an on-premise data center
or a public cloud it's possible that it
would fail and you would have to default
to another availability zone what if you
have to redeploy something while you
have active users what if you have to
load balanced users or redirect them to
another data center so those are the
kinds of things that it would be very
hard for you to do if you had lots of
users when you had to do this manually
so in the infrastructure software
engineering space there have been
several solutions to this problem of
managing large-scale containerized
applications that need to have high
availability and these are known as
container orchestrators they take care
of two main things for you so first they
manage a cluster which is a collection
of cloud-based or on-premise machines
the term the applications point of view
look like a single machine so your
jupiter hub single notebook server
shouldn't actually care
which actual physical or virtual
machine' they're being deployed to and
what handles this deployment is the
orchestrator it's schedules and manages
containers it makes sure that there is
adequate compute power on the virtual
machine where the container is scheduled
and it can also do things like failover
and act as this help healing system so
if a node in your cluster becomes
unhealthy for whatever reason the
orchestrator can deal with this so if
you go back to the Jupiter hub project
there are many many container
orchestrators that are in use these days
but the Jupiter hub project has chosen
to go with kubernetes which is an open
source orchestration system that was
first developed at Google to handle
their large-scale or container
application loads so what kubernetes
does in a nutshell is it has a master
component this component manages a
cluster of nodes which are for example
virtual machines on your favorite cloud
provider and it takes care of scheduling
containers scheduling applications -
load balancing failover and making sure
that the state of the cluster is always
in the desired form so there are two key
things that have been very interesting
about kubernetes so first of all
kubernetes has introduced what's known
as declarative infrastructure
definitions so ten years or so ago when
you were first preparing your server to
deploy your application you could
potentially SSH into the machine and
then run a batch script or run a series
of commands that would prepare your
machine to host your application so
these days that's known as an imperative
infrastructure definition and it's no
longer in use so instead of it's no
longer an used widely I should say I'm
sure there are still places that that
provision infrastructure in these ways
but what's different about kubernetes is
that instead of defining the steps that
should be taken you define what you want
the state of the infrastructure to be so
for example I could say I want 3
replicas of Jupiter hub running but I
don't tell kubernetes how to get to 3
States instead kubernetes continuously
monitors my Jupiter hub deployment and
when it detects that for example one of
the jupiter hub processes has failed
it's going
try to be self-healing and bring up
another process to replace it the second
thing that's important is obstructing of
infrastructure so instead of dealing
with the actual physical virtual
machines and network interfaces we're
dealing with abstract objects such as
pods which represent the service a
process or services which represent
logical sets of pods and an access
policy that users can use to access them
so in theory at least this should be
make it easier for people who aren't
very familiar with infrastructure to run
applications on kubernetes so this is
basically how you define a service in
kubernetes if you write a configuration
file and then you deploy it to the
server for small applications once again
this is okay but if you have to write a
lot of llamó you will very soon have a
bad headache
so what kubernetes does is it has a
package manager called helm and there
are two components in it one of these
components sits on your client machine
and the other one tiller is on the
cluster so your client machine receipt
your client machine talks to tiller and
tells it how to deploy applications on
your kubernetes cluster and this is also
the route that the open source Jupiter
how project has chosen to go to so they
basically provide a home chart for you
which makes it really easy for you to
deploy your Jupiter have applications
once you have your cluster up and
running so to prepare for this
presentation I try to deploy Jupiter hub
on three different commercial cloud
providers and compare a little bit the
costs and ease of deployment in doing
this so as you might know Google they
sort of have a monopoly are on
kubernetes services at least until
recently so they have an offering called
google kubernetes engine which is a
managed solution this means you don't
actually need to know too much about
running kubernetes because Google takes
care of that for you so the good thing
about this that things usually work out
of the box you can check out the Jupiter
hub helm chart from github run a few
commands on your local shell and you'll
have a Jupiter hub a working Jupiter hub
running quite quickly the other nice
thing about this also is that you only
pay for the Google compute engine
instances that make up your node your
nodes you don't actually have to pay for
the machines that run the kubernetes
master itself so if you want to try out
a small cluster for your Jupiter hub
deployment with just three nodes and
each of them is one of our Cho CPU in a
bit of RAM you can get away with about
an 80 euro bill per month and this will
be good for a small demo maybe like five
to ten notebooks and nothing to CPU
intensive so next one is AWS so until
recently AWS had no easy way of running
a kubernetes cluster instead you had two
two options if you are feeling a bit
adventurous and wanted to do some
do-it-yourself deployment of kubernetes
so you can use a guide produced by a
company called hefty oh and a
CloudFormation template which is
Amazon's way of writing configuration
for for infrastructure components or you
could use a command line tool called
cops which makes it quite easy to to
deploy a kubernetes cluster that you
manage yourself on AWS you know the two
downsides of this are is that you will
have to sort of be an expert in how to
deal with kubernetes problems in case
something goes down and you have to
debug it whereas with Google Cloud you
don't really deal with that stuff
in addition you will also have to pay
for the virtual machine that runs the
kubernetes master and it's quite a large
machine so that will definitely add to
your bill last but not least is Azure
container service which is quite similar
to the Google cloud offering in the
sense that it's also a managed service
so you don't have to actually deal with
installing kubernetes or deploying any
of the components it is a bit new on the
market so there are still a few hiccups
but overall it works quite well so I
also try to deploy Jupiter hub onto here
and it works pretty much out of the box
the very nice thing about helm here is
that once you have set up your
kubernetes cluster your Jupiter hub
application is pretty much portable
across cloud providers the only thing
that's different is the actual process
of setting up the cluster once you have
that installed you can just use helm and
all of a sudden you can deploy to pretty
much any cloud provider that it supports
kubernetes so I try to compare the is
your container service with the
- vignetting sanguine in terms of cost
and although the two providers don't
have machines that are exact replicas of
each other I found this one which was
quite close to the one I used for the
Google Cloud cluster and it's also three
nodes with one core and a bit of RAM and
the bill for a month if you leave it
running 24/7 is 98 heroes so they are
quite close in terms of cost so if you
work in a company and you want to try
out Jupiter hub on Google Cloud
I suggest coming up with this kind of
decision matrix that will help you make
a technical decision so when when I work
with teams that need to make a technical
decision we usually write the things
that we care about is it easy to deploy
how well can I use home charts what is
it going to cost me and so forth and
then we go across the cloud providers
and we see how well they check our
expectations against it so for example
at the moment I probably would not go
with AWS until they have a managed
kubernetes service just because you need
another team to take care of your
kubernetes deployment or at least
someone who knows what they're doing so
when I gave this talk at PI data London
a few weeks ago a lots of people came up
to me to talk about scaling and whether
how easy it would be to run this at a
very very large scale so the things that
you need to think about here first are
how many users you will have and what
kinds of workloads will they be running
if users are just using this to learn
Python for example it's very different
than doing some large-scale matrix
computation or computing fractals you
also need to think about how the spike
of load is distributed so if you're
running a class it's very likely that
everyone will want to log in at once if
you are deploying this for a team it
could be true that the load is more
distributed across the day but either
way the open source Jupiter hub project
has provided a handy Python notebook
that you can use to estimate your costs
and it's linked on the slide there's
also a very nice case study from a data
science class called data eight which
had a thousand plus users and the
notebook that's been
the link will tell you a bit about how
they've budgeted for their class to make
sure that they stay within limits last
but not least on this slide is a very
very interesting talk about by Scott
Sanderson who works at canto pian I
don't know how many of you have heard
about canto pian but it's a community
for doing algorithmic trading in python
and they run their data science
infrastructure on jupiter hub and so in
this talk he talked about running
jupiter hub for a hundred thousand users
it's quite impressive in addition to
mentioning how they do scaling with
multiple jupiter hub instances and load
balancing users between different
jupiter hubs scott also talks about
managing state with Postgres so
definitely recommend watching this talk
if you're planning to to scale up
jupiter hub to hundreds of thousands of
users so in summary we've seen what the
Jupiter project is what the ecosystem is
and how to make it easy for you to
provision large-scale Jupiter have
deployments with Jupiter hub we've taken
a look at some of the things that go on
in Jupiter hub under the hood and also
the infrastructure components such as
containers kubernetes and others that
make it very easy for us to deploy
Jupiter hub in the cloud so I believe
I'm doing ok for time and there is time
for questions so this is all I had and
I'll be happy to take your questions now
or through email you're perfect in time
thank you
I said they decided my side but myself I
found it very useful so thank you again
and it does anybody in the room have a
question for her sorry yeah thanks for a
nice talk I'm gonna ask us something
maybe a little bit off-topic but it's it
is there any chance of running Jupiter
hub on Windows these days as I work in a
hospital and they believe in Windows so
do they believe in Windows 10 not yet
there is windows subsystem for Linux
which is what I actually have running so
I think this might like it actually
gives you a shell with a distro so I I
believe that this could be the answer if
you want to run run it on on Windows but
unfortunately I know the project
maintainers have have said no to Windows
a few times unfortunately I think the
answer's no for now okay thank you
hey thanks and talk it was great do you
have any advice for running like
cpu-intensive notebooks like if you have
a team like how do you manage the
resource allocation and these kind of
things I think at this point based on my
research you will have to do a trial run
first so you would start with a like a
very small cheap cluster and then have a
few sample notebooks and start up like
ten servers at once and see time the
time it takes for that CPU in terms of
resource to execute and keep monitoring
your cluster through some of for example
the built-in monitoring tools but
unfortunately I don't think there's a
systematic way to determine how many
nodes you would have upfront if you just
need to experiment right do you have any
documentation support for handling
authentication for instance with LDAP
but the helping shots can be edited to
handle your internal LDAP server so
there's a there is a whole guide about
doing authentication with different
kinds of providers you can do
authentication if you're if you have
just Linux users for example you can map
them you can use all with github Google
wide variety of things and there's also
an LDAP Authenticator I think I haven't
set it up myself but I believe I saw it
in the dock so there is a support for a
wide range of authenticators I have a
scenario so for example in a classroom
if many students are trying to use the
same data set I can so there's a lot of
duplication essentially in the RAM so is
there any clever solution to deduplicate
in some way to reduce the usage do you
mean your students all download the data
set from like in a three bucket or
something yesterday or download the mes
200 and digits database it's like a
hundred times the same exact same data
set in the memory so so you could attach
some kind of volume and put the data set
there and then everyone could access it
it still solving the RAM so when they
load it into so there's no solution well
I mean if your students are manipulating
the data set I think it would be pretty
dangerous to have them share it
at the same time but I don't know of any
solution Thanks any other questions all
right so thank you very much coming up
please give her another warm applause
[Applause]